I have tried not to work in politics on
several occasions because you know it's
a drag I mean it's miserable people yell
at you they don't like you half the
country hates your guts it's just too
fun I just can't help it
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special
I'm eager somewhat eager to welcome to
the show Michael Mills the execrable as
you know him the host of the Michael
Nolan show Michael
somewhat thank you for stopping by Ben
thank you for having me is is that word
by the way when I listen to the show I
always hear the excellent Michael
Knowles it's the is that the that that's
that's totally now it means this okay
well look absolutely okay so you know
let's start with current events and
start what's happening now so you've
been watching these Democratic debates
every minute I don't know how you've
been doing it I've had to I don't drink
I've had to drink heavily I will say
that that sniffing glue was still on the
table you know how's the experience been
for you what was your takeaway from the
from the we've seen now two rounds of
Democratic debates what's your take away
so far my experience is very simple I
put a little crystals all around my
couch as I sit down I get the orbs and
the dreamcatcher is hanging from the
ceiling and then I channel the dark
psychic force that is the 2020
Democratic presidential debates and then
it all makes sense when you realize it's
all a dark psychic force and that
marianne williamson is the most sane
person on that stage then they all sort
to make sense because you know i'm
mostly joking about marianne williamson
but she actually had i think it was
three of the most accurate sentences in
that debate the most recent debate the
first one is that wonkiness is not going
to decide the democratic nominee ain't
gonna nobody cares about the
bean-counting of how many zillions of
dollars of our money they're going to
spend on x y&z social program the second
one is about the dark psychic force
because it actually is the case that
politics at bottom is cultural and even
below that is theological there actually
is a spiritual component to politics
it's not all just adding up numbers on a
spreadsheet and then the third statement
that i think she made correctly is that
if democrats don't change their strategy
Trump is going to win
I mean if looking around that stage
which of those candidates is possibly
going to be Trump I think this is
totally right I mean I I pointed out
that marianne williamson every sort of
making fun of the whole marianne
williamson phenomena but she's talking
in a different level than the other
democrats and she's actually making what
is a more honest appeal for a lot of
democrats then the other democrats are
the democrats are fighting with each
other over ism
to care for all or Medicare for anyone
who wants it or whatever and she's
talking about no there's there's deep
rough waters in this country and we have
to investigate that and get to the heart
of it she's speaking to spirit and in a
way that Obama did in 2008 actually no
one cared about Obama on policy in 2008
it was about the hope and the feel of
the zeitgeist and she's doing a lot more
of that than any of the other candidates
so it is kind of fascinating I think
there is something happening with her I
should not be the nominee but I think
that anybody who's able to tap into even
a remote amount of what she's doing it
could create something fascinating and
that was night one of the debate yes
right and then there was night two which
was supposed to be Rock'em Sock'em
robots with Kamala Harris and and Joe
Biden and Coble Harris basically ends up
in pieces on the floor but not because
Joe Biden you're talking about that cop
Kamala Harris you talk about that
crooked cop Kamala yes Kamala had her
candidacy basically shredded by Tulsi
Gabbard it was it was that was the
exchange of the night I mean everyone
was waiting for Kamala and Biden and
Biden pretty much collapsed under the
weight of his of his own vocabulary he
didn't know how to say basic words he he
fumbled sentences it actually I think
Biden's performance shows a little bit
of the cleverness of the Trump campaign
branding him as sleepy Joe when when
they branded him as sleepy Joe I thought
why not creepy Joe why not liar Joe why
not play Juris Joe why not in effect you
it's because he actually comes off as
old tired and possibly senile I mean he
really he couldn't he said go to Joe
three oh three three didn't know the
difference between a text message and a
a website and so the more interesting
exchange was Tulsi and Kamala there were
some actual substantive debates going on
last night I mean you heard debates over
free trade at the the second night of
the democratic debate
you heard debates over sovereignty over
borders there there were these debates
going on but what it became lost in I
think was the sloganeering
of the Democratic Party you know you
hear the universal basic health care
health care is a right not a privilege
they're all going back to this I think
the central figure of the debate
actually was Barack Obama to hear them
talk about Barack Obama I thought gosh
this Obama guy sounds pretty good maybe
this Obama guy should run for office as
a Republican because it's it's this lie
of leftism
they told us in 2008 we're gonna have a
universal how
CAIR it is this is it once and for all
we're gonna fix the healthcare system
that whole obamacare debate we're gonna
do it health care for everybody now we
find out Obamacare was terrible it
didn't do anything it didn't achieve
anything it's never enough with the left
they're always moving further and
further to the left and so they'll say
once and for all we're gonna have
Medicare for all we're gonna have
universal health care until 8 years from
now when they have another program that
costs even more money and that takes
even more of our Liberty away so you
tell me you looked at all these
candidates how do you think this race
shakes out and who do you think is the
most plausible candidate to go up
against Trump if you're advising the
Democrats who would you tell them to
nominate so I called from the beginning
Kamala Harris
I thought Kamala was a pretty strong
candidate she's a killer she's willing
to do anything to get ahead I'll leave
it at that I don't want to say anything
untoward but she's she's made some
curious decisions in her political
career she's willing to fight she's a
prosecutor she has you know I think she
was an unsuccessful Attorney General of
California now they're trying to make
her out to be the toughest AG in
American history I think she's got to
lean into that I think she's got to
embrace that that's her whole career
she's a tough lawyer she was a
prosecutor she was AG she's been in the
Senate for five minutes that's her life
if she runs away from her record she's
got nothing to run on so I think she
could be a good candidate but she's got
to stop blowing in the wind she's got to
stop one day saying we're going to
abolish private health insurance next
day we're not going to abolish it we're
gonna opinion poll and figure out which
way the wind is blowing if she cuts that
out runs as herself I think she's a
decent candidate the other alternative
is Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren has
this crossover appeal the mainstream
boomer side of the Democratic Party kind
of likes her she kind of looks like
Hillary Clinton she kind of talks like
Hillary Clinton but she's got much more
progressive credibility and she's stole
all of Bernie Sanders his plans so she's
got a plan for everything and it's
because she went in and took it out of
Bernie's desk drawer that gives her some
appeal I think the weakness for
Elizabeth Warren I'm there people are
gonna call me a sexist for this it's her
voice and the reason this isn't sexist
is Elizabeth Warren is shrill not all
women are shrill Kamala Harris isn't
shrill tulsi gabbard isn't shrill Amy
Klobuchar isn't shrill
the second shrillest candidate in this
race is cory booker's who ostensibly is
a man so I think they both have to fix
something about their candidacies Kamala
needs to embrace her actual life story
and Elizabeth needs to change just that
the tactics of campaigning just the tone
in which he's speaking if they don't
change those two things it's hard for me
to believe that that any of those
candidates are gonna be President Trump
he has legitimate vulnerabilities but I
just don't think they're rising to the
occasion so you're foreclosing Biden is
the nominee already you think that Biden
is gonna be the nominee I think I mean
look if you look at the polls today Joe
Biden is the nominee right he's still at
the top of the pack he's just so weak
and I think part of the reason his poll
numbers are so high is he's been out of
public life now for a few years even
when he was the vice president he wasn't
really in front of the public so much
they'd rot him at his crazy uncle Joe
every once in a while but Joe Biden is a
doofus people forget this he ran in 1988
and he dropped out cuz he lied about his
law school record he plagiarized
speeches from Irish politicians he's
just a kind of a bumbling fool then he
ran again in 2008 and he was nothing
nobody wanted him the only reason he got
to be vice president is because Barack
Obama hated Hillary Clinton so much he
couldn't stomach the thought of her
being his vice president now he's up
again I mean Joe Biden in his entire
half-century in politics what did he
accomplish what did he actually
accomplish yeah I think he has basically
one piece of legislation that he can own
that was pretty good legislation that's
the 1994 crime bill and it's the one
thing he's running so fast if you look
at those debate stages there's a Joe
Biden shaped hole in the wall he's
running away from his record that fast
so considering all of that the more that
he's in the limelight the more he's
bungling his own record the more he's
bungling even the words coming out of
his mouth it's hard to see how his poll
numbers ever stay the same or go up it
just seems like as you said quite
rightly I think his first day as his
best day and I think he just keeps
steadily sliding down and the question
is can one of the other candidates jump
up and beat him before the nomination is
decided so the other reason that you
have have gained notoriety is of course
because you want to occupy the same
August space as the Alexandra Ocasio
Cortes on the East Coast she of course
is a woman from the heart of the Bronx
you know yes from her self-described
biography grew up on the street Jenny
from the block
the only say that must have been
YouTube's you grew up in the same area
right look I obviously look like Jenny
from the block the only problem with a
OCS Autobiography is that it's
completely untrue other than that it's
all good but it's just completely untrue
so that's the problem with it actually
AOC grew up about an hour hour and a
half north of the Bronx in a town called
Yorktown Heights very ritzy suburb with
very wealthy not terribly ethnically
diverse I mean it's just what you
picture the suburbs to be that's what it
is
I grew up directly next door in the
slightly less wealthy slightly you know
less affluent town and we grew up there
for our whole life she was there until
18 she then went to a private college in
Massachusetts she then according to
Westchester land records moved back
lived with her mother there until
basically until she ran for Congress I
didn't I laughter college I went down
and lived in the city so I'm I'm
actually pretty sure I've spent much
more time in my life in the
congressional district in Queens in the
Bronx that AOC currently represents but
I just can't pull it off as well I don't
know I mean maybe I need to add multiple
last names or dance on rooftops or so I
don't know what it is I just I don't
have that real that inauthentic
authenticity that AOC has mom I mean we
can always hope that you can you can
breed that into yourself and one day you
too can be a thought leader in the
Democratic Party I mean you've already
written the book on it so this is true I
mean you know I think I've written the
definitive work on reasons to vote for
Democrats and yet Tom Perez says that
AOC is the future of the Democratic
Party it's like give me a little look
man give me you know finally embrace
some of the intellectual future of the
left so since you are not the thought
leader of the Democratic Party but
apparently AOC is let's talk for a
second about the squad led by the
illustrious brilliant world breaking a
OSI so the Democratic Party has embraced
the squad which is just an act of
complete imbecility but what do you make
of their rise what why exactly are they
so popular among Democrats right now
well HL Mencken described democracy as
the theory that the people deserve to
get what they want and they deserve to
get it good and hard and I think that's
what you're seeing with the rise of the
squad for years decades and decades the
left has been embracing this
awful petty politics of personal
destruction the political as the
personal was one of the mottos in the
1960s impugning everybody's motives
accusing everyone of racism and sexism
and this ism embracing identity politics
so what matters is not our ideas what
matters is just our skin color or our
genitalia or whatever and the
Frankenstein's monster of this political
experiment is the squat and so now
you're seeing this turn on Nancy Pelosi
now you're seeing this turn on the
Clintons and I can't really feel bad for
them I mean they've been encouraging
this sort of thing the whole time and so
now the chickens are coming home to
roost for the Democratic Party the the
thing about this squad that's
interesting is people have been calling
Ayanna Presley the Ringo Starr of the
squad and they do they all kind of match
up pretty well on on the Beatles you
know so you've got a OCS obviously
McCartney she's the most marketable
she's the most pop you know
Ilhan Omar is John Lennon I think she's
the genuine radical she has a very
strange marital history and Rasheeda
Talib is she's George Harrison so
Elmer's brother is like the Yoko of the
sea he is the Yoko is he the Yoko or is
he the Cynthia let again it kind of
breaks down a little bit but and then
obviously you've got George you've got
Rasheeda Talib she's the quiet one you
know she's the she's she plays the sitar
yeah that's right I mean they're wise is
a symptom of reality TV politics and
politics and show business have always
gone together and they always will go
together but we're in the age of reality
TV politics where the king of reality
television is the president and these
girls I mean they could be a reality TV
show it's all just petty names it's all
accusing people of bigotry and all these
different personal motives they don't
know anything about actual public policy
right it's I mean AOC was asked in one
of her first major interviews tell me
about any aspect of your policy tell me
about your foreign policy and she
giggles and says well I'm not really the
expert she was a major in economics she
studied international relations in
college she's not the expert on either
of those she doesn't know anything about
either of those because it has nothing
to do with
policy itself what the the left just has
sort of pushed that to the side now it's
all just about personal character it's
all just about those feelings man and I
know what you think about feelings
versus fact in politics that's what
that's what you're seeing you're seeing
that the total inversion of of the sort
of politics that a self-governing
Republic is should be capable so we saw
this sort of battle breaking out between
Nancy Pelosi and the squad who do you
think ends up winning that battle so if
you had asked me this a few weeks ago I
would have said Pelosi Pelosi looked
like she was going in for the kill she
was waiting for a moment when the squad
was particularly unpopular and she was
going to go in and just clobber them and
that fight had been going along pretty
well and then what happens Donald Trump
he can't help but tweet and get involved
in this fight and this created a lot of
political problems for the president in
the short term he said certain things
that just weren't true he said things
that had people calling him racist all
that all that it was unpleasant to deal
with during that time however I actually
think the cumulative effect of that was
pretty helpful to the president at least
in so much as it rallied support behind
the squad so within a week or two you
see Nancy Pelosi hosting AOC in her
office big smiles everybody's hunky-dory
in the long run this is the best we can
hope for you know sometimes your
conservatives say we got to get a OC out
of office we got to get Ilhan Omar out
of office no way we ha no more needs to
be the Speaker of the House I want her
to be in every presidential campaign I
want her to endorse every candidate
because say what you will about the
squad at least they're honest at least
the squad is honest about the radicalism
of the left about the radicalism of the
Democratic Party other candidates I mean
most famously Hillary Clinton was really
good at hiding that radicalism she would
say abortion should be safe legal and
rare didn't make any sense if it's if
it's murder it shouldn't be legal if
it's just like getting your appendix out
there's no reason for it to be rare this
squat ain't like that they want abortion
on demand with that apology Ilhan Omar
is praying that people open their eyes
to the evils of Israel she says the only
reason that anyone would support Israel
is because the Jews are buying them off
that kind of dormant anti-semitism old
forms of bigotry on the left is really
coming out with them
and I want to give them a big microphone
I want them to come on my show I want
them to be the face of the Democratic
Party and that looks like that's what's
happening how did you grow up to be a
conservative I understand that you're
still very young and that there's still
time you may end up being a transgender
liberal by the time this is all over but
where did you start
I'll only become a transgender liberal
if I ever want to run for office because
I think it's the only way I'd be
electorally viable at this point I more
or less came out of the womb with parted
hair smoking a cigar campaigning for
Republicans I one of the first
statements I ever learned as a kid from
my grandfather was read my lips no new
taxes which was the line from Georgia
grandfather was George it's true no he
loved he loved bush and he told me this
he taught me how to sing it's a grand
old flag of singing around like two
years old 1996 it was the election of
Bob Dole against Bill Clinton I was
campaigning around my first-grade
classroom for Bob Dole I was the only
person in this country excited about Bob
Dole including Bob Dole because he was a
war hero and Clinton was a degenerate
draft dodger I flirted with liberalism I
had my rebellion for about seven months
when I was 13 I thought John Kerry might
be sort of an acceptable human I don't
I'm not I don't want to say it on the
air I then came back I was quite
conservative and I went through all the
stages that young conservatives go
through you know I was a nine Rand
Objectivist type for about six months
and I was a jerk to all my friends and
then I became more interested in other
aspects of conservative thought and the
conservative tradition and I was working
on Republican campaigns that was my day
job from when I was 18 until until
recent past and I was an actor I was an
actor I was directing opera in college I
was doing play as was doing terrible
movies that are on channel 7000 at three
o'clock in the morning and you know I
think both of those things are pretty
related you know Ronald Reagan said that
a politician has to be an actor and in
the
in the negative sense of this it's
because they're both vain ridiculous
sort of endeavors that are selfish and
self-centered but when they're done
right I actually think it's for the
opposite reason I think politics and
acting or similar because both have to
be concerned with truth
acting is living truthfully in imaginary
circumstances politics hopefully if
you're a good politician you're
concerned with pursuing some kind of
political truth ultimately a cultural or
even religious truth and you have to
like people if you don't like people hey
you're gonna hate acting because all
you're doing is building characters
you're analyzing the human condition and
if you hate people
you aren't going to be a terrible
politician because you spend all your
time at spaghetti dinners at the VFW
hall or at the Lions Club or something
you if you don't like them there are
many other ways to make a buck or to get
your name in the newspaper and so I
think it's why you know especially for
Republicans you see a lot of actors who
are politicians and then among Democrats
you see a lot of politicians who are
actors but it's true in Hollywood every
Hollywood celebrity is endorsing some
leftist crazy political agenda every
other day they're holding fundraisers
for some Democratic candidate I think
it's not just the politics of show
business for ugly people I think that
the two are very similar so I know
there's a lot of people who are watching
or listening to this and they're
thinking this Michael Moses guy doesn't
seem so execrable to me so why Ben are
you constantly reppin on Michael knows
for those who don't know the story of
how you put out a blank book that sold
two hundred thousand copies for no
reason at all and about which I'm
supremely better then maybe you ought to
explain what exactly happened what
inspired you to write a blank book
that's sold two hundred thousand copies
well and actually I should mention you
play a key role in this story I know you
want me as much of this yeah so I I had
been researching this book for my entire
life it's called reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide there's
an extensive bibliography in the back I
quoted through Citadis in the foreword
and I said this is not a book to win the
applause of the moment this is a work
for all time it's eternally true and so
the book has a 250 or so blank pages
about ten chapters all the different
areas of policy
and politics that would be the reason to
vote for Democrats I put this up on the
internet I self-published it cost me no
money it was a stupid joke just to
bother my Democrat friends and family
within three days this book becomes the
number one best-selling book in the
world it was actually blurbed by a
friend of mine do you oh it was you ben
shapiro blurbs this book called it a
thorough work this thing leaps to the
top of the charts and then I as I I seem
to recall this as you were furious that
out because you've written what twelve
books millions as you've written all
these books all with words in them you
see the stack of blank pages starts to
send some of your books best-selling
books New York Times bestsellers and
then this book sells all these copies
and you say Knowles I was furious I hate
this this is the worst thing and then
you gave me a literary agent that's true
I did yeah behind the scenes I'm
actually a nice person but that breaks
the it breaks the sort of fourth wall of
the of the show I think it's masochism
that's what it's got it I don't know the
explanation there is no question I mean
we continue to cut you checks despite
all of this ok so let's talk for a
second about trolling so there's this
amazing troller e on the right obviously
President Trump is a troll you are a
master troll I mean like great aide
troll so why do you think President
Trump does that and do you think there's
benefit to it you want to actually have
something to say you want to actually
effect a message while you're trolling
and I think that's the key here because
some of these guys who have just been
provocateurs have gone down pretty bad
intellectual pathways political pathways
and they just wash up in there nothing
so I think the the advantage to trolling
I mean even that word it's such a 20-19
word well we're really talking about is
the advantage to a little humor in
politics to a little levity in politics
this goes a long way obviously Ronald
Reagan is one of the funniest presidents
we've ever had
he started most speeches and most
cabinet meetings with a joke it just
cuts the tension it makes things so much
easier President Trump is actually the
funniest president we've ever had it's
because he's a professional TV show host
I mean he's a product of show business
for 40 years he just knows how to how to
use a line to get an audience to laugh
and so I think that is very helpful you
know today everybody takes politics so
damn seriously they think it's the
be-all the end-all of the whole world
political battles matter but CS Lewis
pointed this out he said a sick society
needs to talk about politics if you
don't talk about politics the sickness
could get worse but if all you're
talking about is politics then you've
lost the point of the society in the
first place the reason we have politics
is so that we can engage in culture so
that we can worship God as we want to
worship God so that we can have
relationships with our family and our
communities and our civil society and
the that those free associations that
make America what it is a society that
can't laugh a little bit at its politics
that can't take itself lightly doesn't
have that you know the writer GK
Chesterton said the angels can fly
because they can take themselves lightly
it's not that they take themselves
unserious ly it's not that they make a
joke of themselves but they can take
themselves lightly and if we can't do
that in politics
the future doesn't look so bright okay
so let's talk about your brand of
conservatism so there's a lot of debate
inside conservative circles over what
exactly conservatism means you're
obviously the younger generation and
there's an open debate as to what kind
of government we need government
involvement what kind of culture we need
there's a battle between conservatives
and libertarians if you have to sort of
sum up your view of conservatives moment
look like I would I would agree with a
lot of conservative thinkers going back
to say Edmund Burke who I think is the
founder of kind of the modern era of
conservative thought I think
conservatism is in many ways an
inclination more than an ideology I
think that it is anti ideological I
think we try to shun doctrines and
dogmas and manifestos with five bullet
points on them and say this is the sum
total of politics I think the
conservative knows that's never going to
sum up the whole world there I can't I
can't boil down my entire experience of
reality my desires what I wish for the
country the consecration with which I
view my country the the loyalty the the
filial piety that I feel for the United
States I can't boil that down into one
two or three bullet points I think a lot
of it comes out of a love for the
tradition and this is a big divide
you have some people in this country who
love America for all her warts for all
her problems for all the tragedies of
history who say I I want America to move
into the future by pulling on the best
of her tradition by living up to the
best of her ideals and in being more
true to herself and then you have some
people who say no America's rotten
America was never that great like Andrew
Cuomo said I hate America I don't like
the flag
I think the Betsy Ross flag is racist I
think Jefferson and Washington I think
they're racist and terrible I think
that's a major divide and I think there
is a broad space for the Conservatives
who actually want to conserve America to
speak you know there was a long move
we've had this long debate in
conservative circles over which brand of
conservatism gets to claim the true
mantle there are the neoconservatives
they've kind of fallen out of favor the
libertarians the religious right the
traditionalists the trumpian populist
Saul of those it seems to me that there
is it's wonderful about conservatism
that there's that intellectual diversity
that there's a debate that's constantly
going on there maybe I favor a little
bit more of the traditional side maybe
you favor a little bit more of the
libertarian side maybe some people are
more religious right or neocon or
whatever but where we're able to engage
in all of that with a common love of
country and a common seriousness of
purpose that is radically different from
the left which no longer has any
intellectual diversity it only has one
they used to have the blue dog sort of
socially conservative Democrats now they
just have one idea which is
progressivism and you are seeing
progressivism speed up with every single
day it speeds up even further to the
point that now we're calling for open
borders we're calling to dismantle
American sovereignty and we're
disrespecting even the American flag
which is a symbol of the country there's
one of the things I fear I think is that
the reactionary nature of our politics
is is driving this a little bit on both
sides so obviously you've seen it from
the left you seen a reaction to
President Trump the left thought they
were never going to lose an election
after Barack Obama was president they
immediately lose the first presidential
election after Obama's president and
there
so stunned by it that they move into
anti-trump territory anything Trump says
must be bad even if it's the most
anodyne normal typical American politics
when it's apple-pie and motherhood and
the American flag they've decided
they're against it because they're
reacting to Trump and then you've seen
on the right a similar tendency which is
we have to oppose the left no matter
what they're doing and even if it means
embracing some of our worst instincts
and I think this is where I'm more
worried about the conservative movement
than you seem to be and that is that I'm
concerned that in the in the correct
attempt to stop the left there's a
willingness to embrace bedfellows that
are really alienating for future
generations as well as morally
problematic in other words the tent can
become so broad that you end up
including people in the tent who
probably shouldn't be in the tent simply
to oppose the other side I agree we
should kick out all the bigots I I don't
think anybody disagrees about that but I
I don't really think that the right has
embraced bigots at least not in anything
approaching the mainstream I mean I
guess these days they're calling steven
crowder a bigot because he says the men
can't be women they're trying to kick
him off of youtube but i mean the real
bigots the the racial politics guys
Richard Spencer I mean Richard Spencer
is practically a creation of the
left-wing media and the mainstream media
he I don't know five years ago he had a
hundred people show up to his conference
a year ago he had about the same number
of people show up to his conference I
don't see the mainstreaming of that guy
well I guess what I'm saying is that
there's a bit of a politics of
convenience going on so for example for
years I was informed that Russia was a
geopolitical foe of the United States
the minute that President Trump declares
that Russia is not in fact a
geopolitical foe of the United States at
least publicly you know in terms of his
actual actions he's treated Russia
certainly as a geopolitical foe of the
United States there's been a whole brand
of the Republican Party that's come out
and basically become quasi pro-putin you
see my don'ts right I'm not I'm not
totally sure I mean I I see your point
on the Russia thing but it's also I mean
this is why I oppose rigid ideology
we're trying to you know boil
conservatism capital C trademark down to
five or so bullet points is because it
is true Russia was our number one
geopolitical adversary for a whole
century I mean we fought a cold war
against them then we
the Cold War and even during the Cold
War you you saw regularly we would play
off Russia against China and China
against Russia and obviously today
that's more important than ever so I
think for a lot of conservatives after
the fall of the Berlin Wall after the
fall of Soviet Communism you look around
and you say you know Russia is awful I
mean it's an Blamire Putin is a terrible
terrible man but the bigger threat comes
from China China is violating WTO
treaties they're illegally subsidizing
their steel and aluminium they're
stealing our property they're spying on
us they're aggressing on some of our
interests and so we say you know if we
put our focus if we take our focus away
maybe from certain interests in the
Middle East even pulling away maybe from
aspects that Russia wants to intervene
in to focus on China that's where the
real threat will be does it mean you
totally you know cozy up to longtime
foes like Vladimir Putin no but it's
it's a reordering of priorities because
the circumstances and politics have
changed okay so let's talk for a second
about this debate that's broken out so
you talk about sort of the Edmund Burke
Russell Kirk side of my job exactly
inside of the conservative movement made
Patrick Dineen there's this side of the
conservative movement that suggests that
conservatism is really about honor for
tradition and for the past and I would
say importantly about veneration the
idea that we have very little in the
United States that binds us together
especially now now is we discourage
assimilation even as we increase
immigration it's very difficult we no
longer really have much shared religion
we don't have much religion at all and
we no longer venerate the symbols that
we once venerated the flag the 4th of
July fireworks and hotdogs and
hamburgers we don't have that shared
love of country and a no country that
I've ever seen in history of the world
can survive without some sense of the
sacred now of course because nature
abhors a vacuum you're getting new
sacred things you know I mean we've
replaced what would be maybe the
Christian liturgical calendar with the
secular leftist liturgical calendar so
you've got in February you've got Black
History Month to celebrate not all black
people not Clarence Thomas I don't think
he's being celebrated it's to celebrate
a particular view of black oppression in
the United States
you've got Women's History Month same
thing not to celebrate all women to
celebrate a particular view of women's
oppression in June what do you have you
have Pride Month we're now celebrating
the queen of all sins who are
celebrating that the deadliest sin of
all I think what we would all agree on
is there is that's that aspect of
government and of politics and of living
together as a nation and therefore I
think what the question becomes between
say the traditionalists and the
libertarians is what what is going to be
sacred in the country or or can we try
to persevere without anything being
sacred well this is why I asked about
the the role of government because I
think that we largely agree on the the
sacred nature of many of the nationally
binding forces I obviously just wrote a
book with words in it all about the
sacred nature of history and how that
has to be balanced with a limited
government in the absence of a virtuous
people you can't have liberalism in the
first instance yeah we're starting to
see a sort of root and branch approach
to liberalism however that I'm not sure
is sustainable and I'm wondering where
you're coming down on the side well
because on the one hand you have folks
who are basically saying that liberalism
itself this is the Patrick Tinian case
openly as the liberalism itself has
failed that it carries within it the
seeds Lockean liberalism carries within
it the seeds yeah of atomized
individualism and that leads to
libertinism and that leads to the
destruction of the society at large you
don't have any binding forces
specifically because you have a liberty
rights driven Society and then on the
other side you have people saying well
so what is the alternative that you're
suggesting like government imposing
virtue from above so where do you come
down and what do you think the role of
government is in effort well much much
as Buckley did in the 20th century maybe
I proposed a fusion or at least a view
that that I think proposes that it's not
those two ideas are not as far apart as
they may seem why is that because in
part for American conservatives who want
to conserve the American tradition
you are largely conserving a liberal
tradition no one doubts the spirit of
1776 and the importance of liberalism
and I don't think anyone wants to well
maybe some people do but I certainly
don't want to rip that out root and
branch but nevertheless you also see
that liberalism has led to this
atomization of the
people have never been lonelier you have
wide a widespread epidemic of depression
anxiety stress suicidality up 70% even
among teenagers in recent years this is
a major social problem the breakdown of
institutions and the breakdown of love
of country now the role of government
comes in and I think the libertarian
side has not fully grappled with this
because I agree with John Adams that the
Constitution is built for a moral and
religious people and it's not fit for
the governance of anyone else and where
do we get morality where do we get
virtue if virtue as a personal habit
it's a personal choice you have to do it
as the you can either discipline
yourself or a giant government will
discipline you order will occur make no
mistake but if you want to be a free
people and you want to govern yourself
you need to have that discipline
yourself increasingly we have seen this
go away and you've seen increasing
libertinism you can view this in
virtually any social phenomenon that
we're looking around at in 2019
where we can't even agree on the
definition of what a man is used to be a
man was not a woman now today is a man
is not a woman
secondary definition also sometimes a
woman we just don't know the role of the
government comes in here because the the
way that you become a virtuous person
the way that you learn your moral it's
the way that you practice the habit of
virtue is through education I mean
that's what the word education means
that's how you learn to behave and form
your mind and form your body and in the
United States broadly education is a
matter of government that government is
doing it there's there is no kind of
education that isn't coercive would that
we could all have private education and
your parents are directing it but that
just isn't the case and so what we need
to ask ourselves is what do we want the
government teaching our kids I mean that
is it might not be a legitimate role of
the government but it certainly has been
the role of the government for at least
a hundred years and in that time you've
seen the ability to even read the Bible
in school forget prayer in school even
to read the Bible in school has has been
washed away the Bible is the bedrock of
our civilization if you haven't read the
Bible you can't understand any of the
rest
and if government is going to run
education and they're not going to even
expose children to that bedrock to their
own civilization
you're gonna look down the road in 20 or
30 years and you're going to see a
completely unrecognizable Society you've
been going around giving speeches to
colleges getting shot with fake bleach
and and really enjoying yourself out
there no there's a there's an
interesting sort of debate that's broken
out about what the future of colleges
should be you seem to be hopeful and and
I think optimistic about what colleges
should be I'm less optimistic I think
they should be circumscribed in their
authority I think that colleges should
basically go back to either being trade
schools or to not existing because the
fact is that they have lost the thread
there they don't have the capacity or
the willingness to teach Western
civilization anymore if we're gonna have
those colleges well they can exist but
they should be privately funded because
the state is no longer going to do any
of that what's your view on what should
happen with colleges I'll tell you I was
more hopeful before I started my college
tour then now that I finished it and
weirdos are shooting strange liquids
that I don't even want to know what's in
them at me what I'm most disappointed in
in the colleges is not the students
students are ignorant that's the
definition of a student you you go to be
educated so that you can stop being
ignorant and start to know some things I
don't even mind the crazy professors
professors have always been crazy
they've had crazy toss old hair and we
would play a game when I was in college
we'd look down the street and say is
that person homeless or is he a
professor you can't sometimes you can't
tell the problem as far as I see it is
the administration after I was sprayed
with what at whatever at a University of
missouri-kansas city
they arrest the guy fortunately they
drag him out and the next morning the
Chancellor of the University he sent out
a letter apologizing to me of course
right absolutely not he smeared me as a
bigot for saying that men are not women
there was the title of my talk he then
said that my talk does not go along with
the University of Missouri Kansas City's
values apparently their values are men
or women I didn't know that that's news
to me
and then he endorsed the actions of the
hecklers the ones who were screaming
from the beginning endorsing the
hecklers veto this is anathema to
liberal education
at the end he said oh yeah but they
shouldn't get violent lip service to
this as far as I can tell there have
been no punishments no consequences for
these kids this has happened at elite
universities all over the country the
inmates are running the asylum here and
you can't educate anybody that way I
mean that's you the truth is arrogant as
a college president once said you know
at University of Chicago which said
we're gonna stand by free speech they
had these campus disruptions they sent
out that letter you haven't heard a peep
since Purdue University run by the great
mitch Daniels there was all this
craziness on campus he called them in he
said all right I've read your demands
and they said well this isn't a
negotiation president Daniels and he
said you're absolutely right this is not
a negotiation and he said sit down
learn and be quiet and you haven't heard
a peep from Purdue either if the
universities were willing to do that I
think a liberal education is essential
to a free society I mean liberal means
free the liberal arts are the arts of
freedom it's not where you go to learn
how to become a carpenter it's not where
you go to learn how to become a lawyer
or a doctor your undergrad liberal arts
is supposed to be where you learn
completely impractical things history
literature mathematics you learn about
your civilization you learn how to think
then you go to a professional school or
you get trained in some job and then you
go out to the world a self-governing
country will not exist very long if we
totally lose liberal education the
problem is I think these universities
are basically rotten to the core I think
we have to defund them I think you and I
are complicit in this because we maybe
we don't donate to our universities but
we pay our taxes I think we need to take
away the federal guarantees of these
loans I mean obviously if president
pocahontas gets into office she's going
to have 1.6 trillion dollars in student
loan forgiveness it's gonna only
exacerbate the problem but you need a
new model I think they're probably five
universities in this country that are
salvageable and good and doing the
business of educating future American
leaders that's great we should keep
doing that you know let's not forget in
nineteen forty five percent of Americans
got a four-year degree from college too
you've got 60 plus percent of high
school graduates or going to college
many of them won't finish you don't you
don't need everybody to study the Aeneid
that way I mean it would be nice but you
actually don't need it I would save
those handful of colleges I would defund
all of the others and I would find some
new method that is of Education that is
more tailored to the individual students
so they don't need to take out a quarter
million dollars in debt to not learn
anything well one of the things that
you've spoken a lot about is the
failures the universities to provide
context about time constants with regard
to president Trump but this is
particularly true in the field of
history where the university seemed to
be teaching that everybody from history
ought to be evaluated by the values that
we currently hold thus you are a better
person than Thomas Jefferson because
Thomas Jefferson held slaves well you do
not hold slaves you're a better person
than John Adams because John Adams
condemned various forms of sin that he
saw whereas you think that those forms
of sin are okay because they're
consensual you know that that seems to
be the the generalized feeling among
folks in history departments all over
the country who's been an inordinate
amount of time talking about a lot of
historical figures one of the historical
figures that you've gotten a most flak
for for defending as Christopher
Columbus maybe can talk a little bit
about sort of the mythology surrounding
Christopher Columbus and why you feel
he's being not given a fair shake
mythology is the greatest word here I
mean because I'm happy I don't think
that I say the Christopher Columbus is
the greatest man who ever lived he
wasn't I'm I'm totally willing to point
out his flaws he had many flaws but he's
being blamed for things that he didn't
do one of his biographers Carol Delaney
at Stanford this was what she kept going
back to when she wrote about him she
said people especially on the left I
guess are attacking him they called him
a genocide on maniac he didn't commit a
genocide
now you can oppose Western exploration
of the Americas I mean I guess that's
what they're really talking about but
Christopher Columbus wasn't Adolf Hitler
they say that he had a particular hatred
of the Native Americans in reality he
was often defending Native Americans
against the harsh punishments sought by
the Spaniards by his fellow travelers in
even Bartolome de las casas and a
Columbus biographer the great defender
of natives in the New World
constantly talked about how he was
defending the natives Christopher
Columbus adopted a Native American son I
say whatever you want about his time as
the governor of the Indies I don't think
he had a particular vile vicious bigoted
hatred of Native Americans if he's going
to adopt one from his dead comrade and
raise him as his own son this is true of
all history I mean this is we're now
doing this to Columbus or to rather
Washington and Jefferson you know
President Trump in that difficult press
conference at Charlottesville
he said you're talking about robert e
lee now and we can all agree we hate
robert e lee but who's next is it Thomas
Jefferson is it Washington and now
you're seeing schools in California
paying $600,000 to paint over a
Washington mural at Notre Dame
University where I gave a speech
defending Columbus they have a beautiful
a priceless mural of Columbus that
actually shows the history of him which
nobody knows though this systematic you
know a multi-faceted mural they're
putting a drape over it so that nobody
is offended where does this end and this
gets back to the conservative
inclination why I think conservatism is
more an inclination than it is an
ideology it's an inclination
fundamentally of humility of awe of
wonder of knowing I'm not the greatest
guy that ever lived
I don't celebrate pride I don't take
pride in myself I be as aware as I can
of my own flaws and the great gift of
humility one the life is a lot better
when you go through it and you try to be
humble but then you also look back on
history and you say you know maybe maybe
I shouldn't throw stones at Thomas
Jefferson he held slaves I don't hold
slaves so that's one point for me I do a
lot of things that he didn't do that are
pretty bad as well just judging Society
in the 19th century there was widespread
slavery in the United States many people
opposed it but there it was what are
people going to say about us in 200
years the obvious example is we kill a
million babies a year and we
specifically target them for being
mentally deficient we can target them
now for their sex we target them for any
reason at all this disproportionately
affects racial minorities
more black babies in New York City are
aborted than born how is history going
to judge us and if we want grace from
our descendants maybe we should give a
little bit of grace to our antecedents
you know I think generally with the
study of history and with the way we
look at our country I think that we are
standing on the shoulders of giants and
many many people in this country think
that we're flying so we were talking
about college experiences obviously I'm
an Ivy Leaguer you're an Ivy Leaguer
what was your ideally experience like I
went to Yale
basically just before it all collapsed
they start renaming colleges students
shrieking at their professors which
happened later on 2014-2015 I feel like
I was the last guy to sort of leap off
the Titanic is the thing is going down
and I I wrote my essays on two topics
one and in life this was my main essay
was my love of Cuban cigars was how much
I loved I've smoked Cubans or not the
title of it was The Count of Monte
Cristo
I talked about the different kinds of
cigars why I liked them what I thought
they meant about the human spirit so
that was one essay well at that point
they just had to have you obviously well
at that time they were trying to ban
smoking from campus and I love I mean
you can even smoke pot you can probably
smoke crack you can do whatever you want
they have whole sex weeks at Yale heaven
forfend you smoke a cigar and I actually
started a club when I got there see some
guys they want to be the head of the
debate team they want to be that captain
of the football team that that wasn't
going to be me so I founded a club
called the Society for intellectual
growth and reinvigoration or cigar and
we convinced them to fund my little
cigar habit for about four years
Cuban cigars it was wonderful and then
in order to get a little bit more money
for my preferred vice I wrote a review
of cigars in the Yale Daily News so I
got them to pay for some of them too I
don't know how they didn't figure this
out only when I graduated I think that's
when they finally obliterated smoking on
campus so you've been like a full-time
troll for years and this is not like
something new it is that actually you
know freshmen no sophomore year thing of
a sophomore year I had my first
political job and I was working on a
campaign
New York for my friend nan Hayworth and
she was running a challenger campaign
against the incumbent John Hall John
Hall had been in this rock band in the
70s called Orleans and they did the
songs like still the one that blah blah
blah and they did you know they did one
dance with me I want to be your partner
can't you see
so I started this classics of the genre
classics of the 70s saccharine genre I
started this troll campaign on the side
of Nan's actual campaign and it was
called the young voters for an Orleans
reunion tour hall not a DC back on the
road and it was a lot of fun I was
ripping off their songs rewriting them
doing YouTube videos and this was back
when you could actually get organic
traction on YouTube movies now that's
virtually impossible says doing this a
few people were paying attention a few
people thought it was funny but they
made the classic political mistake of
overreacting so I got lawsuit threats
from the band
I got lawsuit threats from EMI music I
got lawsuit threats from the congressman
himself all of a sudden you go from 500
people have seen this video to tens of
thousands of people have seen this video
it's all over the news and I thought
well there's really something here
especially in new media this is an
opportunity for conservatives to affect
the culture more broadly but even
political races in a way that we hadn't
been able to before because the
gatekeepers of the mainstream media kept
us out so from there I hopped on a few
other campaigns I was I was part of the
draft campaign for mitch Daniels to get
him to run in 2012 did a few commercials
with Jimmy McMillan of the rent is too
damn high party we were doing all these
same kinds of strategies and this was my
day job as I was working in mainstream
show business trying to keep my mouth
shut hoping no one figured out that I
was a conservative the craziest moment
of this whole thing happened when I go
on an audition in New York and they said
it was for a live event and you had to
speak some different languages so I go
in I didn't know anything about it no
script and they said what languages do
you speak I said I speak this language
that language and I joked I said I also
speak Esperanto which is this totally
made-up leftist stupid language from the
19th century you can learn in three days
which is how I learned it I said that
probably doesn't matter
and they turned to me and they said
actually client number one speaks
Esperanto I said it's George Soros they
said how did you know that I said lay
there like five people on earth who sued
against moranto he's the only one who
could afford to hire anybody anyway long
story short I end up as a fake sommelier
at George Soros's wedding I am serving
wine to George Soros Nancy Pelosi Kofi
Anan you know the head of the UN oh I
was in the belly of the beast the center
of leftist politics in the world I
thought God no no one knows who I am no
one I can I'm like here I can listen I
can what could you imagine this kind of
sums up my relationship to politics I've
tried not to work in politics on several
occasions because you know it's a drag I
mean it's miserable people yell at you
they don't like you half the country
hates your guts it's just too fun I just
can't help it what is your take on the
president overall what's he doing right
what's he doing wrong what can he
improve on I'm honest I like the guy I'm
you know I'm a conservative I tend to
vote Republican I you know I've got a
side here so I don't view myself as an
umpire that that isn't my I'm not I do
have a team doesn't mean I'm just gonna
carry water for the guy I mean I
criticize Trump a lot I think we should
criticize Trump a lot I think it helps
his presidency when we criticize Trump I
think it pulls him away from some some
of his worst inclinations sometimes it
makes more precise his views on on
policy or at least it explains maybe
what conservatives have thought in our
longer conservative tradition because
President Trump isn't terribly
ideological it's one of the things that
helps him in his presidency but then
what we need to do is occasionally
articulate more of the broad
philosophical basis for some of the
things that he's doing so I think he's
doing pretty well I would you know I
agree with the Heritage Foundation said
he had been more conservative in his
first year he instituted more of a
conservative agenda even than Ronald
Reagan maybe we can take that with a
grain of salt but he certainly exceeded
my expectations there been a few moments
where I felt there were some missteps he
had done something
I don't really like certain pieces of
legislation you know he spent most of
December focusing on that that crime
bill letting people out of prison that's
not a top priority for me I thought that
was a waste of political capital some
people in his camp thought that that was
a great idea that was going to appeal
more broadly to Americans ok it's not
neither here and were there for me the
question for him looking forward to 2020
saying everything's been pretty good the
economy's going pretty well record low
unemployment relative peace abroad two
questions one is the economy gonna
falter if the economy falters hard to
see how he gets reelected so got to make
sure the economy stays chugging along to
the wall where is the wall the wall was
not just part of his campaign this was a
central campaign promise and we just got
that CBP report out a couple weeks ago
said that not one mile not one inch of
new wall has been constructed they've
replaced old wall with there but that's
good but they haven't built a new wall
one because it's very expensive two
because there are environmental permits
you need to get three their zoning
permits look I get that it's very hard
but that was the promise the promise was
a big beautiful wall the president has
gotten some pretty good news on this
front in in just the past couple of
weeks so in 2016 he campaigned more or
less on two things the wall and judges
you remember how important the legacy of
Antonin Scalia and all the Supreme Court
justices were going to be for the 2016
election he was just got a favorable
decision from the Supreme Court 5-4
decision thanks to those two justices
that he appointed that opened up about
two and a half billion dollars worth of
Pentagon funding for him to build the
wall so he could build a hundred miles
of border wall maybe there will be more
hiccups maybe he won't be able to build
a hundred miles before 2020 almost
certainly he won't but if he can run on
unjust that decision and say see how
important it was that we got those
judges see how we if not for those
judges we wouldn't have gotten this wall
funding if not for electing me obviously
we wouldn't have a president who wants
to build the wall that's a step in the
right direction but he's got to keep up
the pressure on that if he
doesn't show a clear path to building
that wall I think he's gonna lose a lot
of credibility even among those of us
who want to support him now one thing
that you you haven't mentioned anywhere
in this sort of analysis of Trump is of
course Trump the man and yeah in 2016 I
was deeply concerned about a number of
things about Trump one of those things
was conservative policy he's delivered
on a lot of those fronts although
obviously on spending he's blown it out
yeah because no one cares about spending
apparently enough to actually stop it
but I'm not gonna talk about policy with
regard to Trump because the fact is that
what makes Trump a polarizing figure is
not in fact his policy it is his
character and one of the things that I
was always worried about was that he was
going to poison the well with suburban
women who's gonna poison well with young
people by polling data he's doing that
so the question going forward and I want
to get your take on this is how much has
his character affected the future hopes
of the Republican Party because they're
growing demographics in this country who
look at the Republican Party and see
President Trump and see his tweets and
what can President Trump do if anything
to mitigate that because I think you can
run on all the good policy you want if
the American people are forced to do a
referendum on Trump's character I mean
they were able to escape that by instead
having a referendum on Hillary in 2016
but let's say the Democrats were in a
default candidate like Joe Biden and
he's basically just a piece of wood and
they they they put up this piece of
wooden they said and look at this
horrible man from what can trump do or
what should he do to mitigate the fact
that the president does what the
president from says what he says what a
lot of crap comes out of that mouth you
know I think there are two questions
that this brings up one is the president
a bigot is he a racial bigger there that
everyone calls him a bigot right this is
the mainstream media always calls him a
bigot and he says things that raise that
question I think it's clear from his
life that he isn't a bigot I'd you know
he used to pal around with Al Sharpton
and Jesse Jackson no one called him a
bigot until he ran for president is a
Republican if he's a white supremacist
he's the worst white supremacist in
history he's the least effective because
we have record low black unemployment
record low minority unemployment we have
he's appointed plenty of ethnic
minorities to his administration his
justice reform criminal criminal justice
reform sure he he'd married his married
off his daughter to a Jew he has a town
in Israel named after him so not even
just talking about bigotry toward black
beef
but make a treat toward Jews bigotry hey
I just I don't see evidence of that I
don't think neo-nazis and white
supremacists get towns in Israel named
after them so on the question of is he a
bigot
I think it's clear he isn't does he say
things that make people call him a bigot
yes is he responsible for what he says
yes would they call him a bigot no
matter what he said absolutely they
would and so in terms of the perception
they're gonna call every Republican
every conservative everybody slightly to
the right of Hillary Clinton a bigot
that's too bad the good news is though
political memories are really short so
we're living in the eternal present I
mean there are candidates who ran for
president 2016 maybe you would remember
who they are because you live in this
99% of people in this country have
forgotten the names of many of the
people who ran for president just last
election cycle so what does this mean
for the future of the party to the
tweets matter I don't think so
there's a little non-traumatic I don't
think so what matters is is he going to
be effective in office they said so many
things about Ronald Reagan a new
controversy has cropped up of calling
Ronald Reagan a racist but they said it
all about him during the 1980s and then
Ronald Reagan became a saint he was a
saint on the right even many people on
the Left talked about what a great guy
Reagan was one of the most popular
presidents in American history why
because his administration was effective
at bringing about economic growth
bringing about mourning in America
making Americans feel good about their
country again making Americans love
their country again at a time when
people didn't feel so great about
America gave gave us a quarter century
of that kind of reputation and and and
that legacy from from Reagan there are a
lot of parallels to today I mean there
there is a great malaise in America
there's a there's a epidemic of despair
going on in America you have the average
life expectancy actually decreasing
because of suicides and drug addiction
people just don't feel very very good if
President Trump hopefully after eight
years is able to make the economy boom
fix our border crisis make our country
more of a stable country again make
Americans love their country again not
protest the American flag but actually
review
the American flag if he can do that if
he can bring about a sort of mourning in
America I think all the tweets are gonna
fall away and people are gonna look
fondly on this period and that's gonna
bode very well for either the Republican
Party or more importantly conservative
ideas for the near future and then in 25
years we'll have to fight it all again
so one of the things that's been very
troubling for people on the conservative
side of the aisle who would like to see
President Trump be victorious get done a
lot of conservative things is the fact
that he seems to step on himself an
awful lot there there are a lot of
situations where he is so obsessed it
seems with the trolling he's so obsessed
with tweaking people that he goes out of
his way to tweak people he'll go out of
his way for the joke and we all have
friends sort of like this but it can
lose you a job and it can also make sure
that you're a lot more unpopular than
you need to be and so putting aside you
know the question of Stu his personal
his personal feelings about race which I
think you know for a lot of folks
remains an open question the question of
efficacy of efficiency in how he
presents himself how do you think he's
doing on that because there do seem to
be two schools of thought on this one is
he's got the base the base already loves
him they're never going to leave them
and then there's a bunch of people in
the middle of the country and they look
at his tweets and they're off-putting
and he's putting himself behind the
eight-ball by continuing to do what he
does and then there's the sort of more
Pro Trump view which is this is all
strategy or maybe he's revving up the
base and there aren't that many people
in the middle where do you fall on that
particular debate I think he's good at
show business which actually takes in a
lot of those different opinions I don't
know that he's sitting there plotting
out every single thing that's going to
happen I think he just knows how to
deliver a line he knows how to make
people react to him in a certain way and
so you're right I mean a different
politician who isn't Donald Trump you
got to remember Trump is an American
original some people try to emulate him
doesn't work you nobody is going to out
Trump Trump Marco Rubio tried it in 2016
didn't work out so a different kind of
politician a Mitt Romney style
politician might focus on economic
issues might downplay cultural issues
immigration things like that that's
never going to work for Trump Trump is a
product of the culture
forget the culture wars he is a cultural
figure for the last four decades and so
I think what he's done
is
in some ways he's made himself unlikable
I have a lot of people tell me I like
what Trump is doing but I hate the
tweets I wish he would smile more I wish
he wouldn't talk about Mika Brzezinski
space sure I see all of that but what he
does in his provocations in the tweets
is one he speaks directly to the
American people he gives you a sense
that you're you're really talking to him
sometimes he'll say yeah my one advisor
wanted me to do this but then my other
advisor told me not to I think they're
both idiots
this is what I'm gonna do I mean he sort
of gives you a window with all the
misspellings and all the strange
capitalizations and all of the gossip
and even sometimes all of the cruelty to
members of the staff you get that and
what you get as a result of that out of
totally provocative statements and
actions is you get a left wing that
today is calling to decriminalize border
crossings a left wing that is protesting
the American flag at a broad level we're
not talking about one or two players in
one or two sports we were talking about
a broad movement here you're getting
people to disrespect the United States
to refer to the fourth of July parade as
a fascist endeavor you're getting a not
insignificant portion of this country to
compare the United States to Nazi
Germany because aoc and the squad are
referring to immigration detention
centers as concentration camps comparing
it to Auschwitz or Dachau or something
like that this means that even if
president Trump's approval rating is low
I mean in 2016 we had two candidates
with very low approval ratings even if
his is low he's running against people
who were actually disrespecting the
American flag of the 4th of July they
might as well campaign against apple pie
in the country itself and I think it
puts him in a good position we would
probably agree Trump has a lot of
weaknesses going into this 2020 election
if the economy starts to falter then
he's got serious weaknesses the only
question is who could beat him and of
this crowd I don't see anyone who could
especially the way that that party is
trending so I want to ask about sort of
your religious turn I want to save it
for now because I didn't want people to
literally keel over and die of boredom
in the middle of this actual thing so
I'm
I'm gonna ask you to refrain from
quoting doctrine too much but I can
Salinas encyclicals and know Latin why
actually the good thing is I actually
can't speak in Latin so that's helpful
okay perfect but you can tell it to me
in Esperanto if you really like it but
how did you become a religious Catholic
as for a while you weren't
I was a total atheist I was you know a
baptized R I was born cradle Catholic we
were I was always very interested in
religion I actually read the Quran
before I read the Bible I was I I was
always sort of fascinated with religious
stories but about the time I was 13 I
fell away I don't know I can't
psychoanalyze myself obviously
thirteen-year-old boys go through a lot
of things but intellectually at least I
was convinced that religion was childish
this was at the time of the rise of the
so-called new atheists Christopher
Hitchens and Richard Dawkins and your
buddy Sam Harris and all those guys and
it was just very popular at the time
looking back on it now I think that
their arguments are perfectly tailored
to 13 year-olds but if I was a 13 year
old and so at the time I was taken with
them and I went along with what is
probably a very popular atheism for
about 10 years then I noticed something
when I got to college everyone there was
very smart I don't mean to say my
classmates were stupid they were really
sure the smartest of them were Christian
Orthodox Jews actually and I felt the
smartest of them of all were really
interested in religious tradition the
little Catholic of the restor Orthodox
they were liturgical but they they
really had thought it through I thought
that's strange I thought all the smart
people were atheists I thought all the
stupid people were religious then I
heard some religious arguments one by a
Calvinist philosopher actually Alvin
Plantinga he popularized the modal
ontological argument there are many
other arguments for God the two mystic
arguments from Thomas Aquinas there was
a very nice Protestant evangelist who
handed me CS Lewis one day just
apparently accidentally as I'm walking
across the quad and I gave it a read and
I thought oh this is pretty smart and I
became fairly convinced that God exists
and it was only after all of those
intellectual arguments had taken hold
after I had appealed to my own
intellectual pride hubris that the sense
of the religious started to set in a
little coincidence here
there there's a line from Alexander Pope
who says all nature is but art unknown
to the all chance direction which thou
canst not see and when you look back on
your life you see Direction everywhere
what are the odds that this would work
out in my own wife I've seen it a lot
Bal you know blank book and all the
other thing so that got me interested
coincidentally actually the place that I
saw that quote was on a book at a table
at an event I was at it was a signed
first edition I turned it over Bill
Buckley had blurbed it and said save
this as a first edition I had been the
Buckley fellow when I was in college I
looked at where the church was it was
right down the street
I started going and it just all clicked
and this was now I guess years ago at
this point and the more I think about it
the more endlessly I could think about
it I mean obviously that we cannot
comprehend God we can't comprehend the
faith I can't you could ask me a million
questions about my faith that I would
have no answer for and Cardinal Newman
said 10,000 problems doesn't make one
doubt I think that would exceed if I had
a faith that I could perfectly explain
to you I can promise you it's it's not a
true faith but it's something you learn
you know your pal Andrew Breitbart I
never got to meet him he said politics
is downstream of culture and Russell
Kirk the conservative writer pointed at
the cult and culture come from the same
word the culture is actually downstream
of what the culture worships and that's
religion and it's been said many times
that at bottom all political
disagreements are really theological
disagreements and you know this if well
we'll have a cigar well you'll have a
bubble pipe but well I'm zero is it a
drink or something like that are we just
talking about politics the whole time no
way it always gets down to deeper
questions and what I fear for a society
that abandons that is one you're gonna
have really shallow conversations to
begin but also everybody's got to serve
somebody people have a lot of religious
views they read the horoscope they
believe in crystals some of them are
religions that are focused on their diet
or on their yoga or on whatever
everybody's got to serve somebody and so
I think if you're a serious person you
should take those questions seriously
because ultimately eternally those
the questions that matter so other
religious question that it comes up a
lot and this is not just for Catholics
obviously this is troupe revenge uncle
Protestant Orthodox Jews as well is the
dealing of religious people with
President Trump so the religious people
are sort of conflicted on this so on the
one hand president Trump has given them
a lot of their priorities and when they
look at the choice between okay man who
we think lacks character but is not
going to attack religion and folks who
may have more personal character but
also are going to spend their days
attacking religion or calling us bad
Christians for not applying it their
sense of social values that choice is
pretty easy but one of the things that I
think that a lot of religious folks have
fallen into is an inability to deal with
the cognitive dissonance so it's turned
into President Trump is the be-all
end-all we will defend him no matter
what he says because political warfare
is political warfare and my great fear
for religious folks is that just the
same as for conservatives generally you
undermine your own credibility when you
refuse to call out sin so long as the
sinner happens to be promoting your
particular viewpoint how should
religious people be dealing with this
dichotomy and President Trump well as
always they should do it honestly but I
I think Trump in some ways gets a little
bit too bad a rap and it's not because
he's this morally perfect person but
it's because he just gets a really
really bad rap if I'm judging the
integrity of my president one of the key
features that I'm gonna look at is if he
keeps his promises he keeps his campaign
promises there have been a lot of
studies on this the Heritage Foundation
famously did one he's been pretty good
on the promises he's enacted a
conservative agenda at a pretty fast
rate they said in the early days faster
than Ronald Reagan that shows integrity
that shows you know specifically with
the case of moving the US Embassy in
Israel to Jerusalem every president said
they were going to do it it had been US
policy officially since the 1990s and we
knew they weren't going to do it George
W Bush campaigned on it he didn't do it
Barack Obama campaigned on it he didn't
do it Donald Trump campaigned on it I
never thought he would do it then he did
it I said way to say you're not supposed
to do what you said that you're gonna do
even when it comes down to trying to
open up talks with North Korea even it
comes down to things that you might not
like like trade tariffs he's actually
followed through on a lot of what he's
saying I think that does speak to a
certain kind of character now is he a
thrice-married lapsed presbyterian
yeah he might be but who am i comparing
him to what when I'm looking at
politicians if I could be ruled by an
angel I would vote for the angel but
politicians generally are pretty sordid
and corrupt people and those who seek
the presidency are often the most sorted
and the most corrupt so I don't see any
conflict for me I sleep easy every
single night I don't pretend that Donald
Trump is you know a living saint or an
angel but I'm really pleased with what
he's done and I think he's actually in
the office demonstrated considerable
character in case in just a second I'm
gonna ask you how we convince young
people because the polls among young
people are particularly awful for
Republicans we're moving the wrong
direction in terms of religion for young
people so what is the first step toward
winning young people back that will be
the final question but if you want to
hear Michael Moses answer you have to be
a daily wire subscriber to subscribe go
over to daily we're calm you can click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation there also when you
subscribe to get my show you get nolza
show if that's something that after this
and could possibly want but go check us
over at daily wire comm and click
Subscribe well Michael that wasn't as
bad as I thought okay so thanks for
stopping by
thank you for having me see you next
time
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis flower and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer Colton
Joss
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Manor
post production is supervised by Alex
and singhara editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed my mic Purnima hair and
makeup is by Jesuit alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]